okay I have some really disturbing news
to report to you about the Constitution
which social and uh constitutional
conservatives claim to really value
Donald Trump said late last week that he
would support trying u.s. citizens
suspected of terrorism in military
tribunals this is yet another one of
Donald Trump's hair brain suggestions
that is at worst unconstitutional and at
best would be tied up for years in court
if Donald Trump actually tried to do
this Trump said to the Miami Herald that
he doesn't at all like the idea of
trying terrorist suspects in the
civilian court system and he added that
he would be quote fine with trying u.s.
citizens in military tribunals for
example at Guantanamo Bay in Cuba now
the only problem with this Louis is that
there is this thing called due process
which US citizens are entitled to due
process generally defined as quote fair
treatment through the normal judicial
system especially as a citizen's
entitlement military tribunals Louis not
exactly the normal judicial system are
they not quite this is to me this is
just typical Trump pandering uh and it's
pretty easy to pander to conservatives
all one of the top three things you can
do is just talk about the military and
yet and now we're talking about the
military and and treason and terrorism
and and tribunals I'm sure they're
eating it all up this actually came up
here in Boston after the Boston Marathon
bombing it was suggested by some that's
a hard tsarnaev be tried in a military
tribunal and of course many more
level-headed Republicans like John
McCain for example as well as anyone who
has even a passing understanding of the
Constitution were opposed to that trump
I don't I you you've presented the
possibility Louis that Trump is
pandering I actually want to suggest
that he just has no idea what he's
talking about that this is more
ignorance than anything else because
whenever Trump says one of these things
and is asked to follow up question about
it immediately it's clear that there's
nothing there right uh the the the wheel
is spinning but the hamsters been dead
for a while is maybe
one way we can sort of think about
what's going on there I think the guy
just doesn't have the slightest idea
what he's talking about military
tribunals military yeah I mean I don't
know sure it sounds kind of good I agree
and I I'm picturing his response now to
a follow-up question on military
tribunals you we just talked about uh
how how much we are in danger because of
terrorists yeah uh but I would say that
the two about just being clueless and
pandering are not mutually exclusive no
and there's a big overlap if we imagine
the Venn diagram of both pandering and
being clueless there-there's actually
pretty significant overlap there yeah as
so uh it's both for sure but um I don't
really know how effective this is the
this method of pandering but but talking
about the military talking about how
strong he wants to make the military a
lot of fans love it I like when Trump
says something completely off the wall
like this that would make you question
even his mental stability and then
Republicans like Paul Ryan will respond
by saying something like I'm opposed to
suggestions by Donald Trump that his
opponent be killed if she wins but I do
support the Republican Party and we'll
be voting for Trump in November right
Trump suggests ignoring the constitution
in putting US citizen suspected of
terror into military tribunals I support
the Constitution and the rights afforded
to all by it and Donald Trump's comments
are not representative of the Republican
Party but I will be supporting Donald
Trump in November as he is the best
option for our country every time one of
these comments is made there's some
slightly reasonable Republicans who say
these are dangerous comments that i
disavow but we've got to keep Hillary
out of the White House and I will be
supporting Donald Trump in November as a
lot of those people there's a lot of
that sentiment and unfortunately we're
stuck in this two-party system and can
you imagine if Hillary Clinton suggested
ignoring the US Constitution in this way
the entire right wing apparatus
including up establishment Republicans
and right-wing media would say that that
statement alone dis qualifies Hillary at
large right big picture from being
president of the United States Trump
says it offhandedly sure let's just put
citizens into military tribunals barely
a blip
the right-wing media radar yeah Hillary
would there might be riots if Hillary
said that legitimately gamefly is sort
of like Netflix for video games they
have over 8,000 new and classic games
for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s